hey guys what's up today we're going to
talk a little bit more about why
Deadpool kills all other movies the team
that helped sell Deadpool to us just won
a major award for all those crazy as
they developed you may remember some of
them like the 12 days of Deadpool during
Christmas things that you normally
wouldn't see them do selling a big
Hollywood movie so what that did is it
helped Deadpool crush its opening
box-office most of the time all that
crazy social media stuff you see going
around before movies helps get people
into the movie theater the weekend a
movie opens usually after that what
happens in subsequent weeks is if a
movie is really good word of mouth will
get people to either go back and see it
again or get other people to go see it
so Ryan Reynolds narrated this big video
explaining exactly each step of what
they did so I'm going to play that here
and I'm going to explain a little bit
more about why they were only able to do
this for Deadpool and Marvel can't do
stuff like this for Captain America or
even you know Fox doing it for the big
main x-men films Deadpool is one of a
kind so here we go
oh hello I know right whose balls did I
have to fondle to get nominated for my
very own key art I can't tell you but it
rhymes with Wolverine every year there
are hundreds of movies but only one can
have the best integrated campaign and
this year that winner is gonna be o me
Deadpool so case you'd be happy to sit
on so everybody grab a dick it's time to
get this industry circle-jerk going
yeah no no no after ravaging the box
office with my master Ettore masterpiece
whoops you weren't supposed to see that
and breaking all sorts of records why
such a douche a hashtag drive-by
the one question people always ask is
how did you do it well I'm glad you
asked
cheer the music first I dropped a sexy
bear rug pick simple solid sensual
you're welcome then I announce that my
movie was a hard [ __ ] arm by
tastefully murdering Mario Lopez he's
later phobic then it was on to comic-con
aka nerdgasm 2015 one room ten thousand
virgins not a dry seat in the house I go
with you but I don't wanna
and then the moment came trailer numero
uno Conan had beautiful ginger sex
nothing change the rating of his show so
I could be extra naughty and debut my
red band trailer and all of its glory
all I had to do was give him full body
massage with a happy ending
low where is your ass where is your ass
it's not my fault
oh and that trailer it's still the
number one red band on YouTube to date
suck it every other movie ever oh just
to those christmas came early all over
the internet's face when i dropped 12
days of Deadpool while the NBA was
playing bee ball during JC's bday I
scored a slam dunk with my own Christmas
theme TV spot twas the night before
Christmas and a good guy in red was
hunting down bad guys and making them
dead and what's that under the tree
Timmy a dead clown no it's the premiere
of my second trailer that one only
garnered a mere 90 million views mmm
humble brag then I began to plaster the
world with my billboards and I mean they
were everywhere seriously everywhere I
got concerned letters from women in
Calcutta trying to figure out what
happened to van Wilders beautiful face
and it is one thing I've learned it's
that marketing takes balls what yeah
that's why I encourage men to touch
theirs to check for testicular cancer of
course
hashtag touch yourself tonight because
that bag of beans bouncing around in
your hand could be trying to kill you
every guy between 18 and 29 was DP
curious
it's time to put balls in the holes so
it was time to focus on the ladies we
titillated them with my supple but firm
ass during a bachelor oh that's good
we even conned them into thinking it was
a rom-com what's a nice place like you
doing in a girl like this now we're on a
roll
Wham and it was time to get weird we
confused old people with our emoji
billboards what is that that's the [ __ ]
emoji I thought it was chocolate yogurt
for so long
I even got Betty White to review the
movie once in a generation a movie comes
along that your whole family will love
if your family is a good up group of
kissing inbreds
I love that silly old finally it was
time for the big game
seeing my ugly mug during a super book
was pretty spiffy I always wanted to be
a professional athlete because I wanted
to have children and cities all over the
world and nothing gets me more excited
than sweaty dudes trying to penetrate
each of his insides that came out wrong
leading up to the premiere we horde out
my movie like no other and guess what
the press ate it up Deadpool Deadpool
Deadpool Captain
no just just just Demerol yeah I swear I
could have taken a [ __ ] on live TV and
within five minutes it have been a meme
on BuzzFeed when we hit the theaters we
not only shredded the competition we
shattered records of all kinds and
changed the superhero game forever and
that's the story of how uncle Deadpool
got nominated for his first Golden Key
Art Award to celebrate I'm touching
myself tonight
oh if we let it
so watching that you can see how they
took some of the fun things about the
Deadpool character and just rolled with
it when they were marketing the film
he's a crazy r-rated character that
comments on a lot of comic-book tropes
so their marketing strategy relied
heavily on that in it paid off big-time
this award that they made this video for
they actually ended up winning because
this video was made a little while ago
before they actually announced the
awards so they are definitely going to
be doing stuff like this when they're
selling the second movie and I know a
lot of you are wondering how come they
don't do this for other comic-book
movies like if it works so well in the
problem with that is the audience that
they're trying to sell the movie to so
all the Marvel movies are great Doctor
Strange is going to be an amazing movie
but they're trying to get families to go
see those movies and if you want to get
parents to take all their kids meeting
they buy like three or four movie
tickets instead of just two you can't
release like a trailer with all the
Avengers fondling their balls or like
you know giving themselves breast exams
you just can't do that
so until Marvel makes an r-rated movie
in markets to an r-rated audience which
is you know basically like young people
18 to 34 or you know a little bit older
than that you won't see stuff like this
for the other comic book movies which is
part of the reason why Deadpool did so
well because it gave us something that
we hadn't seen before like all these big
comic-book movies are typically family
films Deadpool isn't so much a family
film so let me know in the comments what
kind of stuff do you want to see them do
when they're marketing the Deadpool
sequel and the cool thing is is I mean
obviously there's going to be more
Deadpool movies as long as people keep
paying to go see them they'll keep
making them so when we get to like the
third Deadpool movie he'll be able to
make fun of all the big Avengers movies
the Infinity Gauntlet all the crazy
stuff that DC is doing there big Justice
League movie there'll be so much
material for Deadpool to Lampoon it is
going to be amazing
I feel like that's Deadpool's new role
in the movie pop-culture consciousness
is basically commenting on all superhero
movies and you guys really like this so
the Deadpool movie made fun of
self a lot they said the Deadpool sequel
is going to do the same thing but
they're also going to be making fun of
all movie sequels ever so just think of
what they're gonna do with all the
Marvel movies and all the DC movies it's
going to be so much fun
early on when they were dropping teasers
for Deadpool this was actually one of my
favorite pictures like no hard feelings
against DC like Ryan Reynolds the DC
people they all get along but something
like this is just like really funny
tongue-in-cheek but just because it's
been a while and I really miss Deadpool
it's going to be a little while before
we see the sequel I'll probably start
doing more regular Deadpool videos
especially stuff for the comics if
there's anything that you guys want me
to do just let me know in the comments
and be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I will be reorganizing my schedule just
a little bit I'm going to be doing
slightly fewer TV videos so that I can
do more movie and more comic book videos
so I'll explain that in the future
but the big thing is that The Walking
Dead is getting started I'll be doing
episode videos my episode 1 video will
post tonight so be sure to watch it
they've been using the meet Lucille
campaign the AMC people were really
awesome and sent me this Lucille bat
maybe I can get the Deadpool people to
send me some handguns when the sequel
comes out you can click up top to learn
all about the director leaving the
Deadpool sequel and you can click on the
bottom link for the Walking Dead Season
7 negan trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
don't give it to your next